let's do a little review the reviewers
this is where I go to Apple podcasts and
I pull a review and we talk about it and
see how good people are doing it
reviewing our show yeah okay yeah well
this is where we get to judge their
judgment of us essentially although this
one is a bit more of a uh
um what would I call it like I got a uh
an ax to grind oh good yeah all right
this is from shmoopy it's five star
review and this is just representative
of many comments we've gotten all right
a while back we did an episode of Conan
O'Brien needs a fan episode where I
mentioned inkadink a bottle of ink and
you all looked at me like I was crazy
yeah well people are coming out of the
woodwork to defend me oh good that's
nice it feels nice to know and you know
what if anyone should defend you it's
shmoopy
bagels and give
and uh yeah no man is an island freaky
Fritz and Sean the bomb07 yep yep so
here's one of those are your Apostles
yes you're quite the religious leader
Matt is right we did this every time we
played hide and seek or ghost in the
graveyard to see who was it we actually
had one more verse to it as well Inka
dink a bottle of ink the Quark fell out
and you stink not because you're dirty
not because you're clean just because
you kissed a girl behind a magazine love
your podcast love the chill Chums and
Conan is okay too oh behind a magazine I
don't want this person as a fan that was
not something I remember how about who
says time for our little sexual
indiscretion meet me behind the magazine
what does that even mean no no that was
not in the version I had as a kid what's
ghosts in the graveyard I don't know
that one is that a thing it must be I've
never heard of Inka Dinka but I think
some of these things are Regional yeah I
remember when we would play like a game
of you know touch football on the street
when I was growing up this is like the
early 1970s and again this is I live in
Brookline I lived in Brookline
Massachusetts which is right up against
Boston so it's the closest town to
Boston really we would play a pickup
game and if there was any kind of
dispute like that was a foul you fouled
him or no fair you you interfered
whatever any kind of or no you were out
you were out of bounds because you
stepped over towards the sizes lawn
rather than staying on Canard Road
whenever people said stuff like that
if you wanted to passive aggressively
tell the other side okay you can have it
you'd say let them have it let the
babies have their orange juice I
remember we all said that I remember
people that was something people said
just in our area people took offense to
that like they understood it was oh they
understood like no he really was out no
it's fine okay okay yeah I was out let
the babies have their orange juice and I
remember saying that with great
conviction and then of course living in
different parts of the country you tried
nobody says that okay I thought you
tried saying it to someone and they were
like no it is I'm sure I've said that
I'm sure I have tried that in L.A
throughout my career whether I was in
New York or L.A and someone said no that
you know no no that's SK that joke
doesn't belong in the sketch it
shouldn't be there okay okay let the
baby have his orange juice
and I'm sure people just said oh what
first of all orange juice is not
something you give to a baby oh way too
high in sugar no way too acidic yeah so
it the more I've learned about babies
um The more I've realized that it
doesn't even make sense oh yeah the baby
doesn't want the orange juice you know
whether you're on a cross-country drive
or on your daily commute time in the car
is perfect for listening to podcasts
like I don't know this one
T-Mobile covers more highway miles with
5G than anyone their Network helps keep
you connected to all your favorite
podcasts when you're out and about I
gotta tell you I like to road trip
sometimes I do too and I have T-Mobile
and I ca I can honestly say there's
coverage that's important like there's
been times in my life where I'm out on
the road driving around and uh
especially on those family trips you're
out in the desert you want to make sure
you have that coverage yeah what if you
get like your car breaks down and you're
just there sitting there like a chump
yeah with no coverage yeah not this guy
I've got T-Mobile got 5G if you find out
more at t-mobile.com Cy that's
s-e-e-w-h-y did you have apple peaches
pumpkin pie whoever's not ready hauler I
no I grew up in the 20th century what
was it
you guys nobody makes me feel more like
a child of immigrants than the two of
you
this is a lot bubble gum bubble gum what
what's that one Edwardo gum bubble gum
in a dishes do you wish One for the
Money Two For the Show three to get
ready what's up my bro what I don't
think it went much
yeah I don't think you should ever say
what's up my bro the classic right eenie
mini yeah yeah wait a minute Mo yeah
catch a tiger
that goes back to the Civil War you know
but the ones they're saying do you know
him no you're a child of immigrants like
I am and this is which ones do you know
Edward Superman Superman fly away I know
that's it
yeah Superman Superman fly away and what
else have you got that's it get out of
my country USA USA did you say no cuts
no butts no coconuts when people would
when cut in line in front of them
okay I don't know that's what I know
that is there you go I'm American the
things that should be on the citizenship
test when you enter the country No it
should not you're right it should be no
no it shouldn't be no we're doing a list
of what shouldn't be on the citizenship
yes yeah I know yeah like let the baby
have their orange juice I think people
can go in this world maybe that's just a
Boston thing I don't know that's a weird
one it's really weird let the babies and
I remember it saying it with great
you know uh you know sort of intensity
yeah let the babies have their orange
juice we shall move on wow what a stupid
thing to say God I was stupid
I mean if we've if we've arrived at any
conclusion here it's that I'm the idiot
and that you with your Inka Dinka bottle
of ink yeah there's a guy I think he
stinks
he buys a coat I hope it's mink no now
you're mocking what's up bro what's up
bro
go have some orange juice what yeah baby
yeah
ipsy-dipsy Dudley do
yeah yeah I was young but then I grew
my favorite food was beef
there's always be fat to do with you
I'm in Britain I've got to use the loo
that's the one I'm gonna use you know
that's what I'm using I want to see a
fart go can you remember it yeah do you
remember what I said
bodily boo yeah I was young but then I
grew yeah my favorite food was beef I
was in England and I used the loo yeah
when I'm in England I use the loo but
how did I I forgot it immediately but
why can't that become legitimate I want
to hear kids saying that
um okay because yeah
I was a child but then I grew okay my
favorite food is beef house that's where
I think where you lose everybody I don't
think so okay oh you know what I was
honest I had to play the stage at
Bonnaroo the main stage you were there
it was for your when you were on tour
when I was on tour and it was a c it was
just that that reverse shot you see at
uh like Woodstock all you see is people
and then the distance you see some
towers with lights yeah and I had to go
out there and I remembered there's no
subtlety this is a crowd that can hear
plugged in rock and roll through giant
Stacks you can't go out there in front
of that crowd so I remembered what they
liked was when I'd come out and I and
I'd go like Potter Rouge
how do you do and then go
and I did a couple of variations with
that and then I'll never forget
and I had this microphone where I went
let's go get some beef house
[Laughter]
thousands of people suddenly got very
quiet
imagine that parting down the middle and
leaving
yeah
are you ready are you ready
it was a lot of that I realized that's
what they like yeah I just questioned
you know what when you start rhyming
Beef House you it's time to it's time
it's time to bring pink out there you
know
ah
remember Nas
I do
I don't have to bring pig out I think
it's time for you to go into a home yeah
it's time for me to go yeah all right
God bless godspeed get some beef Inca
Dinka bottles no no no no no